[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami mais nounours tu es
bien agitée ce soir c'est parce que je
suis du l'aviez pas lé patron bon les
châles et repentant porosité monde
à l'eau sur la terre je suis bien au
point mort est peu dire
[Musique]
évidemment il a oublié une botte
et juliette à elle apporté son beau
chapeau au soir la compagnie bonsoir
manges tu sais le pan nombreuses la
compagnie et oui cornichons et juliette
has hors pack et je vois que c'était
pour 10 de cornichons à oublier une
botte qui est à oublier son chapeau
sur les larves et y est oui c'est une
bonne idée faisons leur impôt pas quels
ils vont être contents
[Musique]
voilà une boîte nours et aja les revend
merci nicolas
mas une botte
le chapeau
c'est parfait je vais poster ce soir le
paquet à rex prêche comme ça ils auront
demain wata ne ferme pas là je dépose
deux baisers dans le paquet pour un
méchant
et pour juliette à
[Musique]
un salut pour dad à
skhirat compta à huy et voilà vous aussi
vous devez être content je veux vous
voir tes en avant la musique et la danse
moi je vais manger aujourd'hui avec les
petits
gars qu'on ne peut pas se tromper ou
trois noms dont la marée sur tout non
nous vient d'abord aura-t-on et par là
de se voter mais gentiment sans
bousculade
mais on va s'arrêter à dire de l'autre
côté on fait une promenade à
qui sèche à main et j'ai amené à moisie
c'est ça vous plaît tant mes enfants 20
départs basie ou à petit tour par six je
vous prie et c'est réussi maintenant on
chante on sent qu'à
en avant les bons danseurs
aulus le pro dans son lit
hanninen
nuit les petits
la
j'éteins la lumière
un dogme
ni nicolas dort bien petite soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patron vous stopperait deux minutes au
dessus du bureau de poste le plus proche
s'il vous plaît j'ai un colis urgents a
expédié d'accord nounours ben nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette et
de bien vous laver les dents est fait
pour
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir europe mon le seul à
tout de suite pas trop tu es bien pressé
nounours mes amis ma tombe ce qu'ils
vont être contents hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop on vous aussi les enfants vous
allez être contents car nous nous fera
vous raconter une jolie histoire
bonsoir les petits c'est quelle histoire
que tu n'auras pas une histoire d'une
petite fille que vous aimez beaucoup
devinez filippi oui à la côtoient et
commence là je me pose aussi la cote
philippines se leva de très bonne heure
elle prit son tambour et
se mit à jouer si fort qu'elle rêvait ya
toute la maison
[Rires]
le lapin blanc qui avaient dormi dans la
chambre de la petite fille se leva aussi
dibi dibi dibi
j'ai faim moi aussi
répondit la petite fille ronde charmante
halim taguine et gentille le petit
déjeuner sentait bon le papa la maman
philippines et le lapin blanc sacyr à
table
le papa avait une passe de café la maman
une tasse de thé philippine avait un bol
de lait le lap à blanc une assiette
pleine de carottes
ils mangèrent tous avec bon appétit à
l'exception du lapin blanc qui jeta ses
carottes ont l'art
la maman lui apporta alors un magnifique
souffleur mais il shota le chou fleur en
l'air
alors le papa lui donna une belle salade
verte et le lapin blanc goethe à la
salade en l'air
mais lorsque philippines pause a devant
lui un pot de confiture de fraises
tibi dibi dibi dit le lapin blanc se
jeta dessus et mange à tout
ça et là à l'arc et pour moi et pour
remercier la petite fille qui était
devenu son ami il lui donna un gentil
baiser de lapin oui tu as dno mobilier
d'apporter la suite je n'ai pas oublié
j'ai fait exprès et je vous la
raconterai une autre fois quand vous
aurez été ça mais tu nous donnes les
livres oui je vous le donne c'est moins
festif
collection allons les enfants rient
ma
bonne nuit les petits
la g dans la lumière
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
dibi dibi début détient voici le lapin
blanc mais non c'est moi un patron
nounours allons en route gros farceur
bonne nuit les enfants bonne nuit les
enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents embrasse
bien fort vos parents et faites de beaux
rêves
c'est fait pour
bonsoir pom pom boy ne fait pas
attention les enfants nounours est un
peu bête ce soir mais n'ont pas trop je
le suis papa c'est une surprise ba ba ba
une surprise europe mon école pop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
voilà je suis de bras et moi j'ai
terminé ma toilette soir bosse moi où
êtes vous
on était dans les salles de bain fait
notre toilette eau c'est très bien ça
montrez vos mains
bravo eh bien puisque vous êtes si
mignon j'ai une surprise pour vous si
galère qu'est-ce qui nous allons chanter
ensemble l'histoire d'une drôle de petit
chef
et vous répéterez après mois à l'autre
au delà que green compteur en l1 jacques
ortet bouzid mal ce trop plein
[Musique]
il était une chèvre de fond tempérament
du revenaient d'espagne et par le talent
le monde pas le temps de la cueillette
en des temps les dames la kenyane dit
elle entra par hasard dans le champ des
normands béliveau lajoux qui valait bien
trois fronts pas le temps de lecture et
nathan des dons à la dague la guinée
et la codah poiron cantal et bien autant
le normand l'assignât devant le
parlement
par l'atome ne te gêne autant de temps à
la
dette à la chambre s'y rendit et
s'assied sur un banc puis elle ouvrit la
porte et regarda de dentelle la table
que sur une tête tentent de temps à
l'accademia tard
elle vit comme son affaire à l'effort
tristement lors elle ouvrit la porte et
pris la clé des champs à l'automne
d'accueil
dont palau tablettes et des hôtels
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle est amusante à cheikh jarrah encore
une fin
au pad aux patrons j'arrive
je suis en retard les enfants on est
inquiets tu pas on va se bouger tout
seuls comme des grands on a l'habitude
quel enfant
exceptionnel
bonne ou ni
la nuit de noces
[Musique]
pas
bah
voilà notre big n ont pas trop c'est moi
nounours
nous sommes bien amusés et bien en route
mon gros nounours route bonne nuit les
enfants faute de bout en bout
[Musique]
voir les enfants dont les sols europe un
instant nounours à temps il faut que je
te parle d'une lettre que je viens de
recevoir elle arrive decosse c'est un
petit garçon et c'est une petite fille
qui m'écrivent le loup et lili de cross
se loin pas trop vu cross non ce n'est
pas très loin nous devrions aller y
faire un tour loulou et les lits nous
demande de venir d'urgence
ils ont un petit frère qui s'appelle
baby et qui pleure si fort la nuit qui
les empêche de dormir tiens oh oui
allons-y pour relouer ligne c'est un
vilain ce papy je vais m'occuper de lui
je descend vite embrasser nicolas et
pimprenelle
ensuite en route pour les gosses et hop
hop hop hop
[Musique]
bravo ce très joli vous avez fait des
progrès c'est une étonnante apporte
maintenant nos cédant lettre de deux
petits-enfants et cochin loulou et lee
ils nous disent que leur petit frère
baby n'arrête pas de pleurer toutes les
nuits
font aussi nous allons faire un petit
voyage en écosse pour nous occuper un
peu de ce papy mais il faut surtout pas
grondé hqe et bbc le plein c'est
peut-être parce que la foi tiens tu la
boardeuse assez de couvertures de laine
moi je crois qu'il a surtout besoin
d'une bonne fessée tu crois en lui
collant nicolas je vais voir ça dope
droit tient noces à bordeaux si
wright merci pape rhône elle tu es le
vrai petit môme bon
je vais chercher autre chose
merci pas preneur mais je crois que je
suis assez chargé comme ça
c'est affreux qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore
tu allais pas tout toute seule il faut
les laver avant d'aller voir un bébé je
me laverai en arrivant là bas c'est
promis dès que j'arriverai chez loulou
il
allons il est pas
oui on a compris qu allait
elle ne faut pas calme en salle mais pas
tous nos
voeux
[Musique]
10dans nous il m'a pas t'occuper tout le
temps de ce baby en écosse est long je
vais visiter les musées
alain thorelle temps nous acheter des
cadeaux oui mais à une condition
que vous me promettez d'aller au lit de
bonheur tous les soirs
et sans rouspéter nicolas
feuz n'oublie pas ton panier et embrasse
dhabi de ma part on dit aussi bonjour
allenou elie oui je n'oublierai pas la
jette à l'honneur
bonne nuit des enfants
à bien tous à bientôt meneau ce fait pas
bon voyage bon voyage
mon
[Musique]
te voilà bien chargé nounours ce sont
des cadeaux pour baby on n'y va pas trop
oui les vins sont bons en route pour les
cosses mon bon nounours en route pour
les cross à bientôt les enfants à
bientôt
bonheur
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous sommes ravis de
vous retrouver ce soir après notre long
voyage en écosse le lot et nounours est
impatient de vous montrer les surprises
qui n'a rapporté pour vous it is aux
magnifiques surprises
fermez les yeux et ouvrez toutes grandes
les petites oreilles
[Musique]
anthony colin kahl raf ont tiré initiale
dans la rue sont mélangés une belle
pièce doré ainsi que tu veux m'acheter
une
mousse la musique à bulles on entrevoit
la enfer venu
belot
globo
qu'est-ce que tu nouvelles apportées
mal
bosse mâles
bagarres étaient des non mon sac de
voyage
en anglais
ces montages
c'est encore par les français aux mots
lourds dont piou
qui leur a
valu
lui voilà un splendide culte pour
nicolas
[Musique]
voyons nicolas les hommes et les dents
et ghost world tous un
clip en un
mois
un garçon dont même et voici aux chaînes
feront
pronal
[Musique]
c'était beau gosse un pantalon pour
faire du cheval
c'est trop fort mentalement pour une
fille et pour
tout ce que tu nous auras portés aux
noms nous louer lit mais deux gentils
petits amis écossais monte au nez profit
un
délicieux ou d'y
apporter mois plein
qui sont gentils sottise écossais merci
aux preneurs
qu'il est vous êtes vous dit
tu leur diras qu'on va le manger avec
papa et maman
tu es très gentil mon petit nicolas je
peux être gentil le toit alors
m'importune jus
peut-être qu'elle n'irait cette jupe si
tu la veux la donne
et bien moi
c'est un pantalon de garçons -alain si
l'on les enfants ou dodo
ce que je suis content merci petite
soeur
bravo vous avez trouvé la bonne solution
allons
y donne
moon non
nous
[Musique]
allons nous nourrir dépêche-toi me voilà
boss lathus co bonne nuit les enfants
fait bourré
adobe
[Musique]
bonsoir mes amis au droit
au bail d'offres aux morts rue omar lui
que monter tu es bien pressé nounours
pas trop je crois que mes amis m'ont
laissé un peu de pudding a tout de suite
à je
comprends gros gourmand
nicolas se veut faire du bien la
pape rhône être au plus mal au coeur
ollo on a mal au corps du
pauvre petit mais pourquoi
j'ai de monique tout le pudding où le
petit coin
j'ai maintenant si on veut pas être
malade on doit voir ce médicament
si vous m'aviez laisser un peu de poudre
vous ne sauriez pas valable la prochaine
fois nous n'oublierons pas le nom mais
si tu fais un peu de médicaments de gêne
pas ollo merci mes droits qui anono pas
ma grande
les enfants c'est vous qui allez boire
comme des grands et si vous êtes sages
tu nous fais une surprise potter nous
verrons show compte jusqu'à 3
et je ne regarde pas
eu 3
j'ai tout vu
bravo alors nous chante ou une chanson
lui en avant la musique
[Musique]
quand je passais par le bois le coucou
chante
jamais dans son joli chant faisait
coucou coucou
et moi je croyais qu'il disait au public
ou copient le coup et moi du coup
jugements sont veut sombre et moi du
coup jean en sauveur
m
quand je passais par le pré le faucheur
dans son joli chant puzzle à quelle
chaleur en quelle chaleur sèche à
l'heure actuelle chalets et moi je
croyais qu'il disait à quel voleur à
quel voleur et moi du mouvement son
ressort et moi du coup j'ai bon show
et plus
range passait près de l'étang qu'un
arabe sont bons qu'à et jada et dans son
joli son puzzle coin moi
et moi je croyais qu'ils disaient qu'ils
aillent au mois ils aillent au point et
moi du coup je mens son ressort et du
coup je pense au bar
ils se sont sauvés eux aussi
[Musique]
banni
alors vous allez mieux
vous voyez vous êtes thierry la jette à
la lueur
1 devant le petit
adam à nos noces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il était bon ce petit mail à ce
patron nounours n'a pas mangé de poutine
pauvre gros nounours gourmand allant en
route bonne nuit les enfants
tout pour
bonsoir breton du coûteux qui at-il
nounours j'en temple heureux mais c'est
vrai on dirait un jeune chien qui gémit
je vais voir pauvre petit chemin il ne
faut pas le laisser pleurer au
dépêche-toi nounours si tu veux rendre
visite à nicolas et pimprenelle ce soir
voilà voilà
le pauvre petit
pour voir mignon pauvre petit chien
regardez pas trop qu'il est joli où la
trouver dans la rue tout seul il
pleurait j'ai peut-être fin il a dû se
perdre qu'allons-nous infère ndour j'ai
une idée je vais le confier à nicolas et
pimprenelle quelques jours juste le
temps de retrouver sa maison nos mots
gentils toutous je t'emmène tout de
suite de va doucement nounours qui ne
tombe pas hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop 90 ne vient pas ce soir
ben
non je ne vous ai pas oubliés
regardez ce que je vous apporte
[Musique]
un pauvre petit chien peur du coup j'ai
trouvé dans la rue
[Musique]
il est mignon la fois moi je crois qu un
sommeil non il a faim
[Musique]
monuc olemps prados à bébé chien du leur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pauvre petit du bon au niveau ce
qui l'aidera fait peur ils se régalent
les enfants je crois que je peux vous le
confier sans crainte oui on va bien
soigné
et tu vas je vais l'installer dans le
belz automates
porsche
tient à sic et moi je vais essayer de
retrouver sa maison je vais mettre une
annonce dans le journal c'est quoi une
annonce quelques lignes écrites dans le
journal qui diront petit chien perdu
cherche sa famille
écrire ou téléphoner à nicolas et a pas
preneur à
4,600 dartige
[Musique]
sommet oui il a summer
vous
on va au lit
boenisch pour elle
[Musique]
soit change
tout ou
si on ne retrouve pas sa famille on doit
le garder oui il sera bien plus heureux
s'il retrouve sa maman chien c'est
encore à pépé allons en dormez-vous vite
et soigné le bien ses brebis 9 à demain
lundi chronos
bowden
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours il est tard les
enfants doivent aller se coucher et moi
je dois les mettre une annonce dans le
journal
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents faites votre toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous laver les dents
est fait pour
voir les enfants bosse moi vite vite pas
trop je descends j'ai une surprise
devinez pour qui pour patronner les
nicolas
non pour le petit chien perdu que je
leur ai apporté leur europe hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop comme pomme
banane à pettitte ya fait tiguan bonsoir
tous mes enfants
tu sais il est merveilleux ces petits
chiens il est presque aussi gourmand que
nous at il été sage
[Musique]
alors j'ai une surprise pour lui
voilà un gros collier
avec ça lorsque tu es gatti c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut pour l
électrode mais c'est moi qui tiendrait
la laisse non c'est moi comme monsieur
je te dit tu sais pas t'occuper
il préfère se promener avec un homme
neuf panneaux non d'une a doucement
doucement moi je l'emmène ce toutou si
vous vous disputez vous tiendrez la
laisse chacun à votre tour
merci
[Musique]
ils chatouillent le tt chic avec cet
allié
chou
10 points chauds h bah c'est pas sympa
c'est vrai voyons comment te pique
médard
non
d'un sport
non tu crois pas
moi
qui
donne de ce
téléphone on va répondre
[Musique]
alors c'est qui vous demandaient à moi à
moi à l'eau nounours à la parole
bonjour monsieur
j'ai lu votre annonce
j'ai perdu mon chien émile émules
comment es-tu c'est un gros chien tout
noir je regrette monsieur celui que j'ai
trouvée est tout petit au revoir
monsieur
il a émis
deux voulaient passer où il est plus là
mais du petit chien chien alors petits
drôles il est l'heure de faire dodo
viens vite voir manos camp qu'il ait
jamais connu petit chat perdu
[Musique]
madrilena ce bonne nuit le petit
bleu nuit tout où
on la retrouvera ta maman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nounours comment se porte notre
nouvel ami à merveille patron est ce que
l'union est bien en route bonnut des
enfants embrasser bien fort vos parents
est ce que peut
[Musique]
on par les enfants est ce que le petit
chien perdu à retrouver son maître ou sa
maman chez eux nous allons voir ça pas
trop ma petite chaîne
popopopop
teyssot gay ça me regarde et
terrible as tu tombe bien que devant
chez lui j -pd où il déchire tout
regarde ma chaussette mais c'est pour
jouer les petits chiens adore s'amuser
l'on sait lui une balle vous allez voir
et voilà ils courent après
[Musique]
à
nemours pas l'époque je suis paul bol
je pas chercher
au
[Rires]
[Musique]
congo-k attrape la balle ne parut pas
à tous que je t'attrape quoi
encore nos vols je t'aurais petits
microbes
[Musique]
génie
je te tiens
peux-tu trop
[Musique]
aux mondiaux il un sommet tuam un favori
c'est plutôt lui qui m'a fait courir je
crois qu'il est temps qu'il retrouve sa
famille
fait preuve
essoyes charge
carmaux
[Musique]
mais non nous en échange sèvres
bonne nuit les petits
ottoman
annonce
nicolas temps bien petite soeur
[Musique]
alors nounours tout va bien à peu près
pas trop mais j'aimerais bien que ce
petit chien retrouve sa maman pourquoi
il ne tint peu capricieux et pas très
respectueux avec nous mon pauvre
nounours allons en route oui oh tu vas
nuit les enfants peuvent
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants alors nounours tu es
content oui patron j'ai une bonne
nouvelle je crois que le petit chemin
n'est plus un petit chien perdu je
descend vite vérifier si c'est bien lui
qu'on recherche dans ce journal mon
échelle
on prolonge et aimant
à l'enfant la terre je suis bien content
de voir les petits enfants
[Musique]
il alerte reste coucou j'apporte une
bonne nouvelle
in fine ce caissier attentes et je
m'assois d'abord là comment se porte
notre petite amie chien
christ regardez ce journal je vous lis
ce qu'il ya d'écrit j'ai perdu pépito en
le promenant au jardin c'est un
ravissant petit chien très gentil sa
maman chien est très triste et moi aussi
si vous le trouvez et si vous le ramenez
je vous donnerai tout mais bon bon
patricia rue des grands peupliers
pepito c'est peut être l'une des pépites
haut débit
ces pépites op et opu
tôt
il tarde à cannes elle rappelle à ka sat
et python
plus tôt tu n'es plus un petit chat
perdu nous avons retrouvé ta famille
mais il a l'air content à tepito
alors tu vas la mener notre peu plus tôt
oui nicolas mais je te promets que tu le
reverra
très bientôt la rue des grands peupliers
n'est pas loin d'ici vous irez promener
pépites au jardin avec patricia
j'ai juré avec patricia tandis que moi
je mangerai les bombes ou alors pépito
tu es prêt à partir homélie son beau
collier à temps je suis là dans ces
jolis panneaux avec une couverture pour
qu'il ne prenne pas froid
non l'os nous faire tuer maton occupy
auront jeté pendant l'occuper c'est tout
de même moi qui retrouvait sa famille
non il est prêt
ne bougez pas bp tôt soit sèche et
n'oublie pas ta balle allons en route
pépito
et binou allez vite vous coucher les
enfants bonne nuit
[Musique]
2 voilà bien chargé une ourse
le petit chien d'eau vous l'aura non
chez lui pas trop elle va être contente
patricia de retrouver son pépito en
route pour la rue de grands pas prise et
dos nu des enfants embrasser bien faire
vos parents est faite de pour eux
[Musique]
oh